Well,
well,
well go to your mom's house,
Christina.
Let's looks glass glass,
the Moose,
Moose,
Moose.
You ever seen him lose his down?
There you go.
Ah,
that is really good work,
man.
That is really good work.
That's by a Josep G.
Thank you Joseph.
Uh,
welcome to another episode of Your Mom's house.
I am very thin comedian Tom Segura here along with my cohost,
this slightly dehydrated Chris Skiing,
ski,
listen.
Um,
any other Amazon did you talk about that already?
Would appreciate it.
If you guys shop on Amazon for this Christmas,
using our banner header row,
go to your mom's house,
podcast.com.
Click on the banner at the bottom of the homepage.
Do Your shopping as you normally would.
I advise you.
Just do that right now.
Go to our website,
your mom's house podcasts and a.com and click on the banner and go ahead and
bookmark that site.
That way you don't even have to think it's there.
You do your shopping and it just kicks back a little change to the show to help
us.
It's nice new equipment,
new studios.
It's a new husband.
It's all very expensive.
What?
Okay.
Um,
thank you for those who've already done it and I don't know why you're going to
the mall.
We went to the mall yesterday at to pick up with the computer,
right?
Yeah.
I picked up my brain.
It's a new logic board for the old Mac book.
Yeah.
Didn't know that.
And of course,
terrible.
Don't forget this.
Thank you.
a.com and click on the star
gold to Tom segura.com and click on the store.
I get some of the new ship,
Dj Dot Tan mouth the water champ.
Just glass in all the Chet is fire dog.
Hey guys,
I can't believe what I'm saying.
There you go.
You can get your just glass and shirts.
Yeah,
get your water champion shirts.
All of them,
man.
Get it all.
It's all there man.
It all glass glass glass all day.
Yeah,
we had top dog and Charo in here doing some line reads for us.
It's really good.
It was pretty fun.
Pretty Fun.
Well I ask glass glass all day.
They came for our sons smurf day.
He did
got a lot to catch up on.
There's a lot.
There's a lot to talk about.
There's a lots of
talk about,
um,
I also have some,
some great,
I have great audio from them.
I have a,
a bunch of clips,
bunch of audio to play,
so,
oh yeah.
Bobby.
Bobby's ready to be Jimmy and Bobby around.
Let's see.
Do I have the,
uh,
my,
why am h thing?
I don't even know where that is.
Oh my God.
Wait,
which episode was last week?
Why 70 is that?
We don't have the intro.
I don't even have my a show open.
Oh my God.
Where is that?
Oh my gosh.
You think you're ready to go and then you realize how many elements though.
I know he mom realized that there's so many moving parts to a podcast.
We've got the visual,
the audio,
the drops,
so you have to prepare.
And then just getting to the intro,
soc can sometimes be annoying.
I do.
I mess up on that deep,
Bro.
Constantly.
Yeah.
Well the thing is to a new computer,
new pooter,
a new pooter.
All right.
That's a little story for our listeners who don't know,
but Tom got me this computer for me.
Yeah,
just as it everyday mommy and it's so complicated.
I like,
I had a fucking nuclear meltdown because it was the end of the day we,
I spent all day with my kid.
You know how it is actually had a faulty thing out of the box.
We'll get into it.
Let's let,
let's open this show.
Let's start the show and we'll get to the point is I can't,
it's too much computer for me.
Yeah,
because I'm a mom.
All I do is like check emails and look at photos and my kid and now it's our
production.
Right.
I have no use for it.
Yeah.
Do you want to open the shutters for me please?
One to speak to you.
Your money out.
Well,
if you close the shutters,
of course they're gonna try and take my fucking property.
We've got shot as Dan this.
You have someone who looks into your house and says he's going to fuck this
shit.
Oh Shit.
Oh your said,
what are you going to do
right now?
Straight away from what I've seen.
Fuck you.
One cousin.
Then it will be the Winco.
Don't bring anyone in loving to then
go to your mom's house or his own surgical.
Christina,
that sounds good.
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
I'm up in it in,
in the urban dictionary and what comes up dog in a bathtub and you and I were
just having,
well yeah,
like what was there.
It's under,
it's like different trending now words.
You and I were having this very important debate about what dog and a bathtub
is.
Now you say it's the twigs and berries and the beans inside a woman's mouth.
It would be the berries and the beans.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
The twig and the berries.
I'm adding it.
I'm assuming there's two or four gentlemen there.
So yeah,
the twigs and berries.
I'm saying it's the twig in the berries,
inside a girl's machine.
You're saying?
Okay,
so let's see.
Dog in a bath tub.
This is the proper name for when you attempt to insert your nuts into a girl's
ass.
Oh,
that is so named because it can be just are keeping a dog in the bathtub while
giving it a bath.
Right.
We all white.
We know why.
Because you can't keep the berries in.
They pop out,
but they're saying it's anal.
So both of us are wrong.
I have to,
I have to.
I have to disagree.
So Do I.
Yeah.
I,
I'm not anal.
No,
because don't you feel like a dog in a bathtub is hard to achieve in both the
mouse or the vagina?
It's almost impossible.
Yeah,
that's not,
that's not correct.
That's not correct.
No.
I wish we had an authority on,
on the sort of thing.
I feel like,
look,
can I see one thing here?
I want to see if the intro I have here sounds different.
Sure.
I could play the audio in it and then let's see.
Ready?
Cause I know it means,
isn't it?
But sometimes English people use in it and it doesn't make sense.
Like he's like fucking Lancos in it that you wouldn't say fucking wankers,
isn't it?
You know what I'm saying?
Because
short.
Oh,
that sounds so much better.
[inaudible] better sound
there.
You shifted last time when this happened.
Okay,
well here we go.
Matt
says,
Huh?
I say that in my act now.
Oh good,
good,
good.
Well Wyffels mine even a thing you made up.
I know.
I remember because we used to do
accents and then the thing was that you could always do British better cause you
live there and I would do that impression and you were like,
that's no one talks like that.
Actually I get,
I get that all my accents are better than yours.
Oh,
that's a nonsense.
Everybody that knows me knows everything,
knows that.
Everyone knows that.
I don't think so.
I feel like my accents are much better.
This is a really funny,
by the way,
the clip now that your dog shit,
but the and that and that and that.
How to get rid of that one.
That's such a bad fog as fuck it.
Wackos and Avnet.
So here's what's happening guys.
A shopkeeper and the tax man came to collect because he owe taxes and he locked
him in his store.
Nice.
So that's what's going on at the beginning of it.
The guy.
Oh,
the guy's like,
yeah,
the situation threatening to turn.
Really ugly.
Help arrives just in time.
Shit.
Yeah.
Hello?
Hello.
That's the tax guy.
Yeah,
I put that together and make sure,
please.
Yeah.
Colin folks went off the song before he spoke to shut us down inside.
He won't open them.
This guy is going through trying to get his money together.
Putting the shockers for me.
Please face,
want to speak to you.
That's funny that they bleeped him there,
right?
Maybe it wasn't a curse.
Maybe it was like a name or something.
Yeah.
Well if you close the shop is of course they called the Toronto take my fucking
property.
He's right.
If somebody says he's going to fuck this shit.
Oh Shit.
Oh fuck the fuck you
want to see right now.
Straight away from what I've see.
Fuck you.
One cousin you.
Oh,
you can
fucking Wagner's Aetna.
But grammatically wouldn't make sense.
So I guess the tax guy can,
can seize the actual items.
Property.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
A store like that.
When I guess we do that.
The IRS will come and take your and your property.
Yeah.
Oh,
do you think you're talking to now?
Are you gonna Arrest me?
Huh?
Are you going to arrest?
What do I have to do it right?
How are you going to arrest?
What's going to have to pay?
Yeah.
In our country,
the police will be like,
sir,
get back,
sir.
There wasn't a camera there.
They would crack it in the fucking job.
Yeah.
If you get yourself a rest state,
you're not in a position to pay this debt payments.
All you have to take all your stock,
MPF parking park.
Yeah.
That's super.
That's Super British.
He makes 15 P it's nothing.
15 pence is 15 cents.
15 cents.
While he's saying that's his margin on that bag of Doritos,
different gender.
Different business.
Get it.
Yeah.
That's not the business for you.
They don't make any money.
Those people 15 p yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's a bit of a waffle is a bit,
but we're fighting.
Uh Huh.
Yeah.
If you get yourself progress to date position department,
which means I'm gonna have to take all your stop.
Not Stop.
I made fucking 15 pf fucking pack.
That's so British.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
No but no,
but yes,
but no,
but
I'm trying to fucking pay them
something.
It's probably he said his name.
Did you know expensive ciggies are empty?
His,
his uh,
Hey,
I've got a neat question.
You know what they call cigarettes in England?
Hmm?
How do you think it's a bit of a riddle?
I think they call them.
Fuck boys.
Not Fuck Boys.
They're definitely calls far.
Nope,
they're calling bags.
Bags.
But do you think because of the PC thing that now you can't even call
cigarettes?
Fags?
No,
of course not.
I'm a couple of fags cause that's come up.
I'm a fag.
But that's still like we're talking to different countries with different,
but I feel like don't they inherit our political correctness to that word?
They would be like,
why would we stop?
Cause the,
that doesn't mean the same thing.
So why would that affect them?
Because it's fast.
It's like it's bad.
Yeah.
But that doesn't mean what it means here.
Yeah,
I know.
So why would that affect us?
Like them calling us the n word,
they'd have to stop saying,
could you,
how mad,
you know,
big word.
Oh,
you know what I'm saying?
Pull him back on it now.
You've never pulled back.
He can't say,
can you lend?
And they get a pencil.
Why can't you say that?
Can't say it.
Why?
Well,
look at,
let's say they called these Niggas,
you can't be lot.
We'd like a Nigga.
Can't say it.
Wait what?
Say it.
Yeah,
but they've fag is bad too.
Now Fag.
Fag is equal to the n one.
My point is at fag was never bad there.
So why would they care?
Because they're cousins of ours.
So our political correctness trickles across the pond to them.
They don't say the n word.
I don't think so.
No,
I don't think so,
dude.
Bro,
I know there are way more politically correct in some ways than we are.
Mm hmm.
Hmm.
Well,
right in if you're from England,
a lot of British,
I know if you're British,
tell it to you.
Still call them facts.
And is that considered a little bit sensitive to call them facts?
She,
I don't think,
I don't think that applies for this.
I really don't.
Well then you might be right,
but I don't think so.
God Damn it.
You know and it's fun.
Now is how angry you get when the myriad of technology fails.
When the,
the monitors goes to sleep,
you fucking lose your mind.
We got an email.
Your lose your mind.
If I sat down for a minute,
you lose your marbles.
Can we just make a montage of blue ban of Tom getting angry every time it goes
bad.
It's true.
This is short fuse and you shouldn't have such a short piece because Karen
milked you today.
Karen is a fucking slut.
Get the fuck out of here.
Well,
because we,
Karen and Bobby made sweet love this morning and the 10 minutes we had before.
Yeah,
Ellis went down and then the nanny shows up.
So we have nice,
sexy 10 minute window to get married.
11 and it's glass glass all day and you finished.
And I was like,
Bobby,
I love you.
And you're like,
I love you too.
I'm like,
Bobby doesn't say that.
Say that.
It doesn't say that.
What is Bobby say?
Go.
Oh No.
You said,
what are you doing tonight?
And then Bobby said,
right,
there's this girl.
I'm really into,
like Bobby says,
hurtful things right to her face because I'd be like,
well no date.
You,
you know what was going to true Bobby fashion though.
You didn't brush your teeth for me this morning,
which was nice.
I felt like you were in character.
You know it took you to pound town too.
You really got it
like a pig.
Unless she purples.
You know what I noticed about my purples?
What they change color.
Like when I'm just like,
I get undressed for a shower.
Then there are the normal color and then I get in the shower and I get cold and
then now they turn purple.
That makes sense.
It's so weird.
Right,
is affecting,
you know,
capillaries,
blood vessels.
Yeah.
Yeah,
sure.
Does that happen to you and your test to purple?
Purple,
but there's some rebels.
See,
you see different cues sometimes.
I've seen purple balls before.
Yeah,
I mean then there's blood rushes obviously,
so things can change color.
I have.
I've had boyfriends where it's,
it's all skin,
like a lot of skin and then the two beans,
like the two balls,
but then like so much skin.
Why is that skin underneath?
Yeah,
like I know the bag is enormous and then the two beans are just floating up.
You've had big ball boyfriends and where you're talking about what you're saying
that their bag just hangs low.
Yeah.
I one boyfriend who's Peter was like real short and fat and then has nuts.
We'll just hang super low.
Yeah,
that's pretty standard.
You're not a lot of times hang lower.
Sure.
When you're relaxed and warm.
Yeah.
I know that they just drew,
but you're saying,
but it was like abnormal.
It was his name not telling you that.
Why?
Oh,
why am I going to embarrass somebody in real life?
No Way.
They're not going to find it.
I've got too much respect for the men in my life.
Really?
One like you.
I'm not indiscriminate about who I allow mash,
genitals,
mashed.
How was he a lover?
Okay.
How were not great?
I mean not nothing to get married over.
Did he ever try to put the dog in the bathroom?
Oh,
nobody's tried that with me.
Did he do a face squat?
Remember when you used to joke about that more?
The pile driver used to pretend
to give me a pile driver.
That was fun.
I remember.
Yeah,
we do that a lot.
Like when you first started dating.
Yeah.
That's neat.
Why did you drop that?
I'll,
I'll bring it back.
Bring it back tonight.
Do you think people really do that or that's just important?
Uh,
I think people really do it,
but I think,
you know the pile driver.
Yeah.
But I mean I don't,
I don't think it's part is like someone's lovemaking repertoire.
I think it's something that,
you know,
it's like a special special or it's,
people are on coke and they're like,
let's just do this.
Right.
Cause I don't,
I feel like that's not a every day.
No,
it's not like we're kind of just cooking up to this,
you know,
like when you have 10 minutes to do it before the nanny gets in.
You don't,
hold on a second.
Okay.
Hold on.
Hello?
Dad's getting mad.
Oh Man.
Red Ban me blue bag.
Cut this part together.
Watch the rage build.
Hold on.
I'm just a
trying to see where the hell is this thing.
Here we go.
Okay.
We're back.
I'm going to do a police ride along.
Okay.
Hello?
Hello.
Oh,
that's great.
Perfect.
Okay,
that's perfect.
So we'll plan on 6:00 PM.
Okay,
great.
Thanks buddy.
Right.
And it all worked out good.
All right,
we're rolling.
Anyways,
that was a phone call.
I'm going to do a police ride along tonight.
Great.
So the phone call was,
hey,
can you come right now?
And I said No.
And they said can you come in a couple of hours?
And I guess I guess so.
And now they just pushed it to later.
Good.
So I'm doing it right along a writer that I've been working with for months now.
We've been working on this police story for a,
uh,
a script and a,
we arrange to ride along with the,
with it
LAPD.
Yeah.
You're going to see some shit cause you're doing it in Hollywood,
right?
Yeah.
You're going to see some crazy shit.
You know,
my dad used to have a police scanners and the house.
Yeah.
But in the valley,
you know,
but we were used to just listen to all the,
should I wear for this?
Yeah.
For the ride along.
Definitely red or blue.
Like you want to pick a side?
Yeah.
Especially on the fence.
Was he a gang banger?
I was thinking just something loud.
You attract attention.
Yeah.
We'll definitely get something gold in the line of fire is what I want for you.
Like get out of the car a lot.
Yeah.
If you see guns getting pulled,
stuff like that.
You know what?
I bet you're going to see a lot of homeless shit.
Like,
Hey,
there's a homeless dude face down on the floor.
It's going to be a tongue.
It's going to be a homeless,
a lot of mentally ill.
I've done two ride alongs before.
I've done one in Tacoma to Catalonia and I've done one in Hickory,
North Carolina.
Yeah.
And mentally ill,
uh,
drugs.
A lot of vagrant.
And then when I did to come on,
Ya'll come comedy club and I did the ride along there.
I wrote along for,
I dunno,
four or five hours.
He dropped me off.
And then when I,
he texted me half hour later,
the next call was a gun gun called guy pulled a gun on the street.
That was the one I missed.
Well,
it's a Monday night,
so there's less drinking,
partying.
It's a good quiet,
but it's the holidays and it's a holiday.
That's when shit goes down.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Well,
you'll have to give us a detailed report.
Yeah,
I'm going to guess homeless.
Homeless.
Yeah.
Gangbangers.
And it,
it,
it and uh,
you guys some gunshots because remember when we lived in the rampart division,
don't really know what was that like?
There are gunshots nightly,
I would say like once the sun went down and the shit hit the fan,
but helicopter to every night go at night for right along this will,
this will be a boring right along the middle of the day on a Monday,
three shit happening.
Shit.
Once the sun go down,
so I got to pull up at six.
Okay.
And how Hollyweird Hollywood.
So you gotta leave early?
I'd meet the tree.
Yeah.
It's going to be going to be a thing to four oh five there's going to be
traffic.
We're going to look like a couple of boners sitting in that car wide.
I like,
oh no,
you're a boner.
I'm not we,
you mean,
oh,
you and the writer and my writer buddy.
Yeah,
yeah.
Should be fine.
They will be fun to take pictures.
Uh,
if they allow,
yeah.
Yeah.
I think it might put you behind the Mesh.
Hopefully I get to sit next to some perps.
What are you in for?
Yeah,
no way.
Nah,
they'll
figure out some codes.
You know,
there's four.
That means everything's good.
I still remember it when I did the ride along 20 years ago in Carolina,
that the guy's car number was one 27 and that his radio call was one 27
accounting.
So when he,
you know,
he picked it out,
he'd go up month 27 county.
Yeah.
And that was the biggie.
Like I still,
it's still burned in my head.
I would like,
if you wouldn't mind asking for a list of radio codes.
Yeah.
Because there is an app you can download that's the police scanner app and I
downloaded it when we lived in the Rampart division just to see what was
happening around us and I can pick up on summit.
All right.
When 19 all that.
Yeah,
like you know,
a seven 2010 seven Henry ten seven is arrest.
I know that I tend to is like all good.
I think a to 11 is a,
is code for a robbery,
right?
I don't know.
Everyone knows one eight seven s f a.
T is like a,
I think it's a biohazard.
Yeah.
A Art t
faced with the prospect of having his stock taken.
The shopkeepers starts to pull together the cash.
So you've given me,
I ain't taking it in that game to try and slow money is money.
Okay.
Gave him,
he's like coins here you go by.
He gave him coins to pay his tax bill,
which in all fairness,
you know the English don't have dollars.
Single dollars.
They have pounds.
Yeah,
of course.
Coins,
pound,
pound coins.
But they also have paper.
They do.
They maybe get them to transfer it,
but this motherfucker gets paid in pound coins is what I'm saying.
Yeah.
For the Dorito someone gives him,
and he does have a point when he says money is money,
but he's definitely being a dick.
He's making the job a little difficult for the tax man.
Money is money,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Fine.
Given me one English saying Bubba money is money.
It's given me 1010 pounds of shit up to him and trying.
You look so you can pull up 27 pounds,
not painting all this fucking money.
So yeah,
you're getting yourself all upset.
Something else happening.
Yeah.
That guy's got it.
Yeah,
you can't.
Uh,
you can't do that.
These are my old teeth.
Those are the Sears.
Um,
yeah.
Photos we took.
Those are eight years ago.
Nears.
Yeah.
But I brought it,
we got the new monitor.
I had it adjusted down.
It looks great.
And then a blue van came here and we throw up the old picture.
Looks really good.
I'm wearing denim.
I don't think you are,
but I have denim pants on.
Of course.
I didn't want a jacket on.
Really Show my love for the show.
Yeah,
that's true.
Yeah.
Do you want to hit,
you want to see some more love for the show?
Yeah.
Okay.
Check this out.
People have been sending these in.
I told you last week and I don't think I could find it,
but where is it?
Oh No.
I said car show in their head that they don't say in it in the right place
though.
Yeah.
Um,
do you want to tell them how to say it right or no?
Yeah,
I feel like in it,
like I've heard it just in weird places.
See if this one,
yeah.
Yes.
I love these.
Hi Mommy makes jeans.
Oh,
hi mommy.
Can I get a grinding hot white Mocha man.
Good job.
Yes.
And also can I get a sausage and Cheddar breakfast sandwich?
Good job.
They always check if they have it every time I go,
you just have them
know that Turkey bacon
he wants.
You don't want me.
That's fine.
Just leave it at that.
Just the ground of how wide go would be good.
All right.
We're going to be a five for that.
All right,
thanks.
Good word.
It's a good one.
Oh Man.
Oh,
soap.
Now,
which,
which item did he want?
That they were out of the sausage and Cheddar or something that's at Starbucks.
Right?
Or our stocks.
Yeah.
Why are they always
out?
There must be a hot ticket item.
I don't know.
She get more if you think they're always out.
I mean,
get more.
That's true.
God.
And you know,
I just,
I just saw this thing here.
Where is it?
Um,
is it,
is Mcdonald's and Mcdonald's?
Somebody didn't me
and at Taco bell one too.
I saw God,
I haven't been there in years.
Yeah.
Also used to eat there a lot when we lived in the rampart because it was right
by our old apartment.
Remember you get off that,
that sweet one.
Oh,
one X.
I ran it her and it was right there across from,
uh,
Tommy Burger.
Yeah.
It's real cops hang out there at that Tommy worker,
by the way.
That was a Cobb hangout.
That was,
yeah.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's like a,
it's a,
it's a real la institution that I place.
Um,
tell him,
tell him where we used to live your cop and see if you guys can cruise.
He'll probably be like [inaudible] bro,
we can't go there.
I can't,
they're definitely going to be like,
we're not going there.
Yeah.
I told you one time I went to the bank that was just outside of the
neighborhood.
Yeah,
it was down on Wilshire.
Yeah.
And I rode with a sergeant,
LAPD,
sorry,
in the elevator.
So I was like,
I was trying to get an honest answer.
I was like,
what do you think of like this neighborhood?
And he was like,
right here.
Like what?
And then I named our neighborhood like the cross streets.
He was like,
that's terrible.
It's a terrible place.
Really dangerous.
How bad?
He goes,
oh no,
no,
no.
He's like,
I mean there's streets over there.
We won't even drive down the street.
And I was like,
cool man.
You're just screwed if you call nine one one,
right?
Yeah.
I was like,
okay,
that's great man.
Um,
right.
What happened to the,
Hi Mommy.
Thanks jeans.
Is it your mom or your mom's house?
Is this the one that guy,
the guy just did?
Is that Josh almost?
Who just sent that one in?
I'm not sure.
Okay.
Um,
I know it's online.
The cheat sheet there,
right under each other,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
That one went through
the Mcdonald's one.
Where'd that go?
Should be on Chichi.
Yeah,
but it uh,
it's an empty,
it's an empty a thing.
Ooh,
that's a blue band booboo.
BLOOB and empty file.
Uh Oh.
Someone's going to get and the trades taken out of his nest.
Yeah,
but this one.
Okay.
This has something in it.
Let's see.
It's Mcdonald's.
Mommy,
can I get a cheeseburger?
Actually,
two cheeseburgers.
I make chicken with ranch.
No mail.
Good call.
And uh,
a small fry please.
And then what else did we take?
A small fry
your code.
We're going to be
okay.
Thanks.
So ridiculous.
Yeah,
it's so funny.
Really warms my heart that people are doing this now across the country.
Yeah.
If we get,
if we get some international,
uh,
Hi Mommy.
Thanks genes at the drive through.
That would be great.
I really,
really enjoy that.
I know that guy that does the,
uh,
the calls.
That's stupid
Molly.
Thanks genes.
By the way,
Barry,
who makes the barbecue is dropping off that barbecue.
Maybe I could bring the police there.
It's a good idea.
Should I go pick it up with the police because I think those guys would also
want to refer to if you would share the queue permission to share my,
share it with them.
If you,
by the way Barry,
I asked you for that video and um,
you send a still image.
So he did this great call where he did customer service and he,
uh,
Barry did the guy who made that and he,
um,
he had the entire conversation with them saying,
and I direct message him to,
uh,
to send it,
but he sent a still image bearing.
Attach the video.
You touched a still image.
It was really funny.
So we'll play it,
but you gotta you gotta get it right.
Thanks jeans.
Um,
nobody said anything and we've been doing this for a while.
No one's ever said a thing.
Yeah,
we've even done it.
Two waitresses face to face.
Oh,
you used to do it to the Sushi waitress and Redondo.
You would go thanks jeans when she would take her and then you had flirt with
her,
you'd be like,
you look beautiful today.
Thank you.
My favorite thing was to do that cause you were there too.
That's what made it fun because that horse sitting with my wife and I would just
go,
uh,
thanks gorgeous.
But some guys are really good at that though.
I she didn't speak good.
My Dad would do that.
Yeah.
My Dad does that shit.
I mean,
I don't know if he does it in front of other kind of generational girlfriend.
No.
Like don't do it with me.
What do you do when he was with your stepmom?
No,
but he would eyeball waitresses.
Hard.
Hardcore,
hard.
Fucking core.
Yeah.
But with me,
he would just flirt.
It was so gross.
It's nothing's Grosser than watching your dad flirt.
Really?
Except maybe hearing your dad talk about his past girlfriends.
Oh my God.
You knows the grossest when your dad was visiting and your mom,
your mom was planning with Ellis and she was on her hands and knees and your dad
turns me and goes and she hasn't been on her hands and knees in a while for
fuck's sake.
And I go,
don't tell your son that you're going to hurt him.
Three scarves.
I don't want to hear that.
I seen her hands and knees and a while.
Really?
He loves,
he loves those.
What it happened.
If I started flirting,
I don't care.
They won't care.
Right.
They think that we're like swingers.
It will if the woman and does that,
the guy was will think I'm a swinger.
Most actually it's different the dynamics between men and women.
If you flirt with a guy in front of a guy,
yeah.
Most guys go,
I don't want any,
I don't have anything to do with this.
Most guys,
yeah.
You know like some of them will flirt back,
but a lot of guys are like w cause guys see that as is,
um,
is this woman trying to provoke this guy that she's with?
Oh right.
They don't mind going to have to fight.
Yeah.
This can be a violent encounter.
Sure.
That's how guys think,
you know,
smart.
Yeah.
But some women do roll with it on either side.
Some women that are with a guy like their man flirting,
vice versa.
Yes.
I don't,
I don't flirt.
Whatever,
whatever.
I certainly don't know.
It's so gross and disrespectful.
Yes,
certainly.
I mean,
I've never been on a date or out with someone and been like,
oh,
a flirt with other girls.
You know?
It's so weird.
No,
Bobby Wood.
No.
I remember one time though,
we were on an early date.
You owe me.
Yeah,
and I forget where we were,
but I went to ask,
I got up and asked the server or something and when I came back to you went,
did you just touch her?
And I was like,
what?
And you thought that I leaned down and touched her heart,
her box on her side.
I was like,
oh.
And you're like,
Oh,
I thought you touched her.
I was like,
what?
You probably did?
No,
I didn't.
You're always,
you're always flirting with all the girls and stuff.
Like you're flirting with our,
our nanny and stuff.
Let's talk about that.
I know.
So we had to get her,
you know,
our nannies,
this really sweet lady,
Guatemalan Lady and we um,
you know,
Christmas is coming.
We've got to get her a gift and it's hard to talk to for,
to shop for someone like that when you go well cause I thought because it gets
cool around here at night you get her like a nice sweatshirt or something,
but then you,
you brought a good point up,
which is then do they feel the obligation?
Right.
Oh I have to wear it.
And if it's not her style at all,
then she feels obligated to wear it around us.
And that
we went to the department store yesterday and I got the idea,
what about we get her or I get her some panties and a bra,
but like a crotch less one and holes with the nips are,
yeah,
I give it to her and I go,
you let me know when you're wearing it.
You know,
kind of
stand over here or I suggested I go make sure they're crotchless panties.
Right.
But I'm the one that suggested,
I would tell her like,
yeah,
tell me when you're wearing these.
You give it to her.
Yeah.
And you go,
can you tell me a second?
Tell me when you're wearing them.
And then she'd be like,
[inaudible] Mr Town.
He tells me to wear the panties and I'd be like
to tell on me,
give me a signal.
And I know what she would do.
She would look down and go,
I'm wearing them today.
I'd be like,
yeah,
yeah.
Could you imagine anything more soul crushing for her?
No.
To work in someone's home with their child and then
yeah,
it would be,
I have to wear these pants.
It'd be awful.
Where are these panties?
Some people have done that,
I'm sure.
You know.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
I've heard nightmare stories of nannies flirting with the dad and the family and
the family.
Dad and
the guy,
I think in West Palm,
uh,
who turned out to be like a pedophile,
but he also had kind of a sex ring running through his home,
you know,
bring in different girls and the staff would cry in the interviews.
They're like,
the staff was mortified because he had a full,
you know,
he's a billionaire cleaning stuff and there,
there'll be so sad to be like,
the girl is here to see.
The thing about that is those people need those jobs,
so they never,
she needs that.
They need the word,
which is why it's even more messed up if you gave it.
Of course.
So abusive.
Yeah.
We even saw,
I'm like,
I made the naughty list this year shirt.
Right.
Or just so there's that kind of subtly sexy.
So there's the crotchless panty,
which is an overt,
or you do this subtly inappropriate gift,
which is the t shirt that's like,
naughty,
not nice or whatever.
I'm on the naughty naughty list.
She's like,
man,
maybe he did not understand the words.
You know,
like maybe she doesn't.
She's like,
oh,
okay.
No,
you know what kind of naughty I'm talking about.
Right.
And she's like,
so religious and sweet.
She would never,
speaking of sexy,
we saw the arrival last night,
that movie,
and I don't want to be a spoiler,
but first of all,
I had the wrong movie in mind.
I thought,
I thought it was the,
um,
the Brad Pitt movie.
That's not fair because you were like,
I was really excited.
I said was high.
You Go,
oh,
it's a new Brad Pitt movie.
It's,
he's in a war.
I thought it was a thriller,
Love Story.
But anyways,
I'm excited for it.
Arrival.
Amy Adams.
So what happens,
by the way,
it's really cleverly written.
I will say,
I don't want to give away the premise totally,
but we can set it up a little bit.
She is a linguistics professor and spaceships land on earth and they're trying
to communicate.
They get her to communicate with the aliens.
And upon her first communication with the alien,
they're like,
do you like big dicks?
That's what they say to her.
And she's like,
um,
what?
And then they're like,
what's the biggest tip you've ever had?
And she's like,
she like holds up her fingers.
She was like,
I guess like that.
And they're like,
is that a boyfriend or a one night stand?
And then she goes back and she tells a CIA and they go,
what'd you tell him?
And she goes,
I don't know.
And they go,
go back and tell him you like big dicks.
So she runs back and she's like,
I can,
I like big dicks and I don't want to give away at where it goes from there.
But that's kind of the setup.
Don't want
to spoiler alert.
We've already given away too much already.
Yeah.
Those aliens want.
Because at first they're like,
we like read Ed's.
Yeah,
send us the redhead.
Yeah.
She's like,
oh my gosh,
me.
I get to communicate.
Yeah,
it's pretty neat.
It's pretty cool.
And it was kind of neat to see how many dicks there were.
There was a lot how many she can handle and,
but it was neat that they address that early because that's when the problem is
so many of these space movies is they don't address the sexual assertiveness of
the
humans or the aliens at any point.
Like in the Martian.
Yeah.
I don't know why you're laughing.
It's true.
Right?
How does he masturbate?
Why hasn't he requested pornography?
Are you going to come again?
Yeah.
All those things.
Yes.
You figured out food.
You figured out water.
Air,
but what about masterminding?
Yeah.
What about Dick touches and it's good that the aliens,
that's her first order of business.
Yeah,
it's sexual pleasure.
but it's so funny because you'd said Brad Pitt was in it and so Amy Adams is it,
and I was,
I still hadn't figured out that this wasn't the movie that you set me up for.
Sure.
And I was waiting for Brad Pitt.
How far into it?
We waiting for him to show up 30 minutes.
It's still like,
I wonder if the her partner,
the other scientist is going to be Brad Pitt and I'm like,
and then it's not him in,
Oh okay.
It's definitely not,
this is the wrong movie.
And then we both said something like,
Oh this is definitely not as was like that slave movie I was watching 10 you're
just like
yeah,
one of your on that one.
You're not forgiven for it because I remember the details so much.
The is 12 years of slave.
We are,
I got back from Hong Kong.
Right.
And on my way there,
I think I watched this man on the flight.
Yeah.
So we're in Florida.
We're about to go on that family trip.
On the cruise.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm out of my mind cause I have jet lag.
You start watching 12 years a slave.
Either you ordered it or was on HBO or something.
It was on cable.
Yeah,
I was just in bed.
So I watch the first 1520 minutes to eat with you.
And there's this scene and first of all,
the title is 12 years a slave.
There's already,
you know,
you can put together the type of movie it is.
And the scene that I pass out on is the scene where in the very beginning though
on a river boat and a slave tries to stop a white man from raping a girl and the
slave stabs him,
kills him and they throw his body off the back of the river boat,
right?
I'm laying next to Christina and she goes,
oh my God.
And I go,
just give it a little,
give it a little,
it gets funnier,
right?
Like I'm thinking that it's registering completely that that's not a true
statement.
The next morning I get up and she goes,
that movie wasn't funny at all.
And I was like,
yeah,
I know.
She goes,
I was waiting the whole time for the comedy to start.
I'm like,
really?
What of that
made you think that there would just,
there would be funny stuff.
Maybe that was just like the hard set up.
Like,
you know how um,
like Quentin Tarantino movies,
like Django and change is a really serious plot,
but there's also comedic moments to break up the tension.
And it was right around the time that we were seeing Django.
And I thought,
oh,
well,
maybe this is someone else's attempt at doing like the slave,
the story.
Right.
Very few people can pull that off that I was thinking maybe there's a subversive
element to the story and maybe this will get fined all tears.
Gosh,
I know.
I need,
the wife dies.
Everybody dies and he's crying alone.
And I go,
I got to stop watching it.
Maybe not as bad as you'll feel about the arrival.
God,
no,
no giveaway here.
But it's a white bummer for sure.
White bummer.
Now white people love thing.
Upset.
No,
I was thinking about why it is that white people.
So let,
let's do some other examples.
For instance,
the One were,
uh,
Hilary swank as a fighter.
What's that movie called?
Cry.
Cry,
cry.
Babies.
Cry,
cry,
don't cry.
Don't cry.
There's a million of,
what about the butterfly and the whole thing.
Remember that paralysis and there's always like these babysitting retards and
like,
you know what I mean?
All those things are white people like retarded people and death,
cancer,
dying children.
Um,
poverty and I don't like these fucking white bummer movies.
I don't need to see this shit,
this and this happened.
So then we committed suicide
marking marks in it and the daughter gets captured by a pedophile and murdered.
And then it's about her ghost from the other photos of Clint Eastwood one that
was,
it was a good movie.
I'm thinking of the,
she did hers on a book,
the Mystic River.
That's for fuck sake.
Good movie.
But it's still a white bummer.
And I call it white bombers because the awards academy,
they love throwing awards at these movies.
They go and change the category two white bummer of the year.
Like here's the movie that the most white people felt best about being bummed
out about this.
Yes.
And Amy as my cousin loves white bummers like whenever it's the trailer is she
lost her legs and then she can see our daughter died.
He's like,
you want to go see that?
And I'm like,
no,
not at all.
It looks horrible.
And he,
he feels enriched by that.
More depressing the storyline,
the better he feels about it.
You know who likes white bombers show business people.
Yeah.
People who have never had real suffering or hardship in their lives.
Like let's go watch this so I can access feelings.
I can't normally get enough bummers.
That's what I'm saying.
Life is hard enough.
I'm not going,
I don't want to fucking get bummed out at the movie.
I was driving last week and I heard on the radio on the radio,
so imagine I'm not seeing anything driving.
I hear about this kid dying.
Oh my God,
he's five years old and I started crying in the car.
Yeah,
I have to change the station and I just sit there and cry for a while.
But you liked it,
right?
Like that was the most part.
It was horrible.
It fucked up my day.
He died and Santa Claus,
his arms.
Right.
It was a sick kid who's up.
Make a make a wish thing.
No,
that's what I'm saying though.
That 30 seconds of that
bummed me out for the rest of the day.
Well,
they're going to make a movie out of it.
I don't want to see that movie.
I couldn't handle a news blurb about it.
You know,
Meryl Streep's going to play Santa Santa Claus is black,
first of all.
I've always believed that.
Of course.
Yeah.
Why?
But why do you think so?
Why do you think he's black?
Um,
just these kids in Florida convinced me when I was in high school.
Seriously?
Yeah.
Why?
They're like,
of course he's like,
he,
they were black and they just told me,
you know,
he,
um,
he's got a lot of swag and sure it takes care of shit.
True.
And he knows how to move true.
He knows how to like,
you know,
get down that chimney even in a difficult way.
I Dunno.
And then they,
they just told me and I just believed it.
Okay.
So I've never,
um,
subscribed prescribed to the notion that Santa Claus isn't black.
He could be.
I think it's gotta be weird.
You know,
when we were walking,
I never thought about it until we had a kid.
We were at the mall picking up my Mac book,
the worst place on earth right now.
That was horrible.
The wrong mall too.
I forgot about that water.
I'm so hydrated.
Oh yeah.
Wow.
We were sitting there and I'm,
I saw the Santa Claus Sandy Claus line.
Yeah.
And I saw all these,
uh,
non binaries.
White people.
Yeah.
That was like,
oh,
I wonder for them,
with their children,
if it's weird to go sit in a white guy's lab.
Yeah.
It's terrible.
I would think that if I were them,
I'd be like,
no,
let's go get a fucking Chinese Santa.
Right.
Why?
Why no Asian Santa?
I want no black Santa.
Definitely Latino.
Especially in southern California.
There should be a Latino Santa's.
I really do think that.
Now here's my one reason.
Maybe Santa is white.
Yeah.
Hear me out.
Okay.
Uh,
it comes from a European tradition.
Saint Nicholas.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah.
So say Nicole Aneesa,
Hungary,
Saint Nicholas,
you know,
that's,
it's a German,
I believe it's a German stuff.
That Nordic tradition is where Saint Nicholas comes from.
Who brings the gifts?
I've got to say,
I would say sometimes you're good.
Now you're good.
Now there's a,
an,
uh,
say a compass.
Yeah.
In Austria.
Who that?
That's a black Santa.
There is a black Santa,
I remember in Amsterdam today with no vert bought me.
It's the black,
yeah,
it's a
chocolate and it came back and it was a black Santa.
That's the,
it's an evil guy who goes against the children.
Memorize what am I my dad growing up?
Yeah.
So no,
the devil,
sorry.
The debatable goes around the village and if you are bad you get whipped with
branches and they do that in Germany and Austria too.
And he's a black guy.
So that's ratios.
Racist as shit obviously.
But well you've only drank once a day of
or she going to make a big deal out of it.
I've already cleared water champ champ for as long as I've known you.
I mean I've never even seen anybody try to fuck with you or try to take that
title.
I don't even talk about it.
And now just remember the first time I,
you my God,
Phoenix who was on this,
like the standup core and you came up to me,
I said,
sure,
I've never seen someone drink so much water during such a short set.
And that was like,
wow,
I was,
I felt connected to you that you like,
that's what you saw and what I recognize is unusual and I just kept drinking and
no one said a word.
He was almost like if you drank one more bottled water,
someone would have to say something.
Yeah,
you are.
You're pounding the water,
but you got to the point where I don't want to show off.
Yeah,
the water down.
But you let them know like you're not fucking around.
Yeah.
So that is,
did you like set out to be the water channel up or is this something that just
happened or you really need to have,
it's like a calling.
It's like,
did you guys set out to be the fucking,
I dunno,
the Yoyo Champ,
you know you don't that 6:00 AM flight.
I'll be walking through the airport like,
dude,
just don't fucking drink for the next hour.
So you could sleep on the flight,
but you don't do it.
Usually I can't.
My just,
my overwhelming Harry should consume more water.
Takes it.
But it's a competitive thing too.
Right?
It's also,
you're putting down numbers and you share these online with people.
Sometimes people will ask like how many,
you know,
like what's your record?
And I know for for these in a day,
somewhere in the 50s yeah,
yeah,
true.
Yeah,
right.
It's true.
I can't believe you had Joe lie.
I didn't have Joel.
He brought it up.
He did.
I know.
I didn't say anything to him.
This is coercion.
No,
it's not going to do some investigating and we'll see what happens.
We'll see you and I know like gallon wise it's just over three.
Yeah,
it's a lot of water.
But when someone's brings up,
you know dude,
I know this guy drinks a lot of water.
I go shut the fuck up.
That's what I said.
I go,
shut the fuck up.
I go.
Just stop talking about your fucking shitty friend and a shitty water
consumption.
Yeah,
I know the guy drinks.
Yeah.
My man,
my phone,
he downs like fucking 15 year old bottles of water day,
Bro.
Go call me Ted.
He makes,
he might drink a thousand and a day.
Yeah,
it's true.
He just drinks water and peas.
He drinks water and peace at the same time,
dude.
Sometimes he's peeing while he's drinking.
You don't understand
and I feel like I should get less cold water champions
on that note,
let's go water champ.
Unbelievable.
You listen,
I don't know how you got Joe to participate in this.
He just did it and the machine,
he just did it.
You must have a coerced him or or bribed him somehow.
Joe,
I forgive you.
I know that you don't know all the facts.
You only know one side of the story.
We're so I'm empty because I've already drank mine.
Such bullshit.
Oh,
we'll give you this though.
I have to be honest with you cause we steam that.
Is that what the champion.
But Dominique is the poster champion.
Look at those shoulders.
Good job,
dummy.
She's right.
I have horrible posture.
I don't care.
I can't believe you talk Joe into lying like that.
I didn't.
Oh Man.
I'm going to have to talk to him.
You ready for this?
You know what that means,
right?
That's hard.
Knew it's time to do dates.
Thanks for drinking my water.
Fucking rude is shit.
You aren't going to drink it anyways.
Don't worry.
Um,
jeans,
daytime dates.
Go ahead.
There's some big stuff I got to announce.
Are you ready for it?
I'm ready.
Of course everybody knows that I'll be in Orlando for the last week of the,
of the month doing new year's at the Orlando Improv.
Um,
then after that I go to Cannes ass shitty and um,
that starts off the new year.
But what I really wanted to tell you guys are the,
um,
the places that are,
are,
you're in a,
in what?
In difficult.
In danger.
That's the word I'm looking for in danger of not getting tickets anymore.
Number one is Atlanta.
There's single digit tickets left there.
Only singles meaning you can't buy two tickets together.
So that's done.
And we're not adding a second show.
Atlanta,
I love you.
If you're coming,
you got them.
You're in.
Otherwise you're probably going to miss out a,
that is going to be January 21st,
just to let you know.
Mommy Apolis the third show,
it's filling up quick.
Make sure you scoop those tickets.
That is the 29th of January.
Um,
let's see.
Chicago,
the second show is over half sold.
Um,
DC.
Saturday is sold out.
Friday late is almost sold out.
That is in March.
But again,
if you don't get them now,
I'm just letting you know you might totally miss out.
Boston.
Massive,
massive,
huge tits.
That's good.
Uh,
we added a third show at the Wilbur.
That'll be it.
We won't add more.
That's going to be it.
Um,
those go on sale Friday.
If you're listening Friday,
they're going on sale and van Cute cuter British Columbia.
That is nearly sold out.
I don't know if we're adding there.
So if you want to get your tickets,
make sure you
do Portland,
Portland,
Oregon.
We sold out in April,
so we added a second show.
Make sure you scoop them before they're gone.
We can only do two in Portland,
Oregon.
So there will be no added third show there.
Um,
genes.
Go ahead and let them know February 12th.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
To improve.
We're doing your mom's house live.
February 12th,
7:00 PM show.
Get your tickets already her.
That's going to be the,
the first time we do a venue of that size for the podcast,
you know,
and um,
we're really excited if you guys can come out.
We really,
really do it.
Appreciate it.
Also,
I'm May 4th and fifth at stand up live and fart next Arizona,
May 19th or 20th New York.
Shitty at the Gotham comedy club.
June 16th and 17th.
I'm in man friend disco as the punchline comedy club.
So that's what's 2017 is doing it.
Start.
Yeah,
you're good there.
I'm good.
But February 12th guys get your 12 your tickets now.
A big one.
I love doing it.
Live.
It is the like this mash up of the show.
Yeah,
the audio and it's like we're,
you know,
we're doing a weird version of standup because we're playing to a live crowd and
you'd like to take a shit live you far,
you spread your butt cheeks.
Um,
so again,
if you want to see Christina go to thousand ranch dotcom and buy some ticket to
see those big mushy purples,
purples.
That's the top dog blog and Nancy eights mushy purples.
She's fun to have.
Tommy,
would you marry your dad,
or did you marry your dad taught me.
Would you marry your dad?
What'd you,
I'm Chattel and Pauline and buy and you can call me.
There you go.
Says what'd you marry?
Your Mom and your dad?
Uh,
I think I would bury my dad much easier.
It's really never burp.
I'm fucked at the same time.
Could you even say that you live I,
oh no,
you the double pipe classic.
It was so funny.
She's sitting right where you are.
My Dad during them in the middle of it,
it's like,
I know he's not doing what we do,
but clearly you'd realize we're recording audio.
Yeah.
He gets up,
walks out,
opens the door,
gets other people bring like,
what are you doing?
Oh,
I wanted to get them in here and I'm like,
don't you see that recording?
Yeah.
I'm like,
what?
Don't you think that'll screw up the audio of it?
Huh?
Nothing.
He was just excited because it's a showbiz thing.
He likes to be in Showbiz.
Do you want to hear Charles?
All of them.
We had a really good time.
That was a good trip.
It was never know with the folks,
man.
I think everyone feels like that.
Right?
You're like Ah yes cause you,
you don't know.
I think it's easier if it's just the three of us without any sister interference
honestly,
and we'll also,
there's a nice buffer with having a child.
That's the best part.
When you have a kid it changes.
The dynamic changes everything,
but it's no longer about the kids.
The two dogs to distract.
Yeah,
it's perfect.
All right,
here's Charro.
Let me see.
I should do it this way.
The original mommy,
Mommy's this is child and that just glazing.
Glassing has cued me.
It wasn't glazing.
Can I see what I'm saying?
See the whole idea there is that I wrote line reads for them.
Yes,
but especially with her or you just want her to go ahead and read.
Yeah,
no.
Hell,
what is this?
You know,
I don't want her to think too much,
right.
Just just glass.
Just glass.
Can I start again?
Okay.
What's up?
Bleeding Mommy's.
This is chart and I'm just glazing glass instead.
Again,
what sub?
Lethal Mommy's man,
this is Chad and I'm just glassing is part one up and pass it around cause I
want to kiss this guy.
I'm Cherile,
I'm Poli and MB I you can call him neat.
Oh that's okay.
We'll leave it Pauline.
Pauline Callie and by,
okay.
So again,
I'm Pauline and B.
I'm CIARA and Pauli and buy and you can call me
sir.
That's good for her.
Right.
So good.
I don't have time for norm by Knowlura bullshit.
Nonbinary she was supposed to say
you had a guy or again,
I'm both or you can kiss my ass like I don't talk like that.
I have to be honest with you.
Christina is the what?
The champion.
But Tommy is the poster champion.
Look at those shoulders.
Good job to it's hilarious poster.
You have never unknown on come Tommy.
If you have never burp or Fart at the same time,
cause you even say that you have leave [inaudible] the doble pipe classic.
Do.
Um,
can you even say that you don't gain,
she so disgusted with it.
If you have never burp and Fart at the same time,
you even say that you live I own,
are you the double pipe classic?
I honor you.
The double punches go to Tom segura.com and click on the store.
I get some of the new Shit Dj,
that tongue mouth the water champ.
Just glass in all the Chet is fire dog.
I can't believe what I'm saying.
So she doesn't realize it til afterwards.
So that's,
that's the key to it.
Just get her to [inaudible] she was like,
wait,
what did I do?
That's the best part that she also doesn't know slang.
She doesn't know.
Wait,
remember when we went out to dinner the first night they were here and she
worked track suit,
which I admire actually.
I really have.
It's funny to see her in it though.
Cause people are like,
you're an athlete.
But remember when we were at dinner and I was talking to your dad about his
bands and she was getting so upset,
she doesn't like it.
And so disgusting.
But you were saying the key is to add genuinely interested.
The more that you're like,
oh that's neat.
She's like please,
like she gets bothered by the fact that you're having a real conversation about
it and that shit.
Cause if you're joking,
part of her is like,
well this is a joke.
If you're serious,
it bothers her more as,
what was I asking her dad?
I forget how well how I got away with her because we did a long commerce,
I forget,
but you did it real sincere.
Right?
I was top dog way.
He would answer very sincerely and that bothers her more.
She's like,
well you know,
thinking of them eat shit and it's there.
You got to really well cause he goes to ne was a travel day,
messes it all up.
Messes gets up.
She's like,
please remember when the waitress came to the table.
Oh yeah.
He's like,
Oh I didn't tell you who died.
And she started laughing so hard.
Waitress heard him.
I didn't think it had a personality because that's our second time having her
ass.
And he goes,
I didn't tell you died.
That's what he said.
I didn't tell you who died and she goes,
because your dad loves talking about Shit and death was my cousin.
He said it with a smile.
He was real happy about it.
Yeah,
pretty good.
I remember one time my friend say,
will you marry him your song?
And I said,
no,
because that's not my zone.
I remember one time my friend said,
would you marry your son?
And I said,
no,
because that's my son.
Oh,
okay.
I remember one time my friend said,
would you marry your song?
And I said,
no,
because that's my song.
Because we were of course playing off of the,
I was like,
would you ever date your mom
Nafsa
God's face?
Is it still my man?
That's what's up.
Don't forget to go to your mom's house,
podcast.com and it's still work shop.
And then she had a stroke.
I don't know what was going on there without
slurp
shop.
He's
leaving at Hilton.
Just walks out
keeping needs to be bad.
He probably needs to pee pads then because they,
what do I say?
Don't forget to go to your mom's house,
but it doesn't take glamazons through their second page.
Oh,
he's really like coaching.
I really old person.
Why are they coming here?
He was excited.
Oh,
you see that?
Nothing.
Nothing registered.
Hey,
we're recording right now.
Oh,
don't forget to go to your mom's house.
Got Cat dot.
Don't forget to go to your mom's house,
but
I ain't show up through the Amazon banner ad.
Every time you buy some shit,
you are helping the show.
Buy Some Shit [inaudible] store and give it to the knee need.
There's Jeanette buy some shit.
I'm over where stood and give it to the negative in it.
I don't know why.
Excuse me.
To
buy some shitting all over the store and give it to a negative it.
Whoa.
Realize that everybody in the room knows you'd had that come and get tickets to
see Tom Perform.
Life may be after the show.
You can click his bat whole click that.
What is it?
I have no one to say that.
Oh well yeah,
go to the and branch.com and get tickets to see Christina perform live.
She bring balls of her tits.
It's pretty good.
She thought by so now
I can talk like this.
Why don't you put your fire to do this system?
No,
I don't use that word know,
but it's great.
[inaudible] hello?
Come on.
You have to say fuck boy.
No fuck boys.
Hello.
Hey Kid.
Did you like youtube?
Hey Hitler do like loot.
I love stamps.
I got some promo stuff.
There you go.
She's all,
what do you see?
So
Tommy,
would you marry your mom
told me,
gave me a movement.
What?
Please tell me some sad stuff.
My preferred pronoun is the regional mommy.
Oh,
there you go.
She is the lesson.
Okay,
go ahead.
Say it in the mic.
What is glassing?
Glassing is like a,
it's either looking through binoculars or just chilling,
like just hanging out.
Can you also say that I don't use the airport please.
You want me to say that?
Yeah.
Say that.
I don't use the airport as uncomfortable.
Okay.
Shit.
I love you.
I love you too.
You did a great job.
Really a great job.
You know what?
It really bummed me out.
Can I get paid for this?
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Dad Do some too.
Okay.
She,
uh,
I recorded her,
then I recorded him and a total fucking amateur move.
I turned,
I stopped recording,
started doing shit,
you know,
then they start talking
and I come in,
I come in a little late,
but he's telling her the Orlando Airport Story.
No,
no,
but I get part of it,
but then I stopped again and now I'm like,
okay,
we're done.
She's sitting on the cash behind you and she has a 22nd fart.
No.
And you know what,
if we had the farm,
yeah,
Mike,
we would have heard it or justify the,
here's the lesson by the way,
if you're ever it here.
Yeah.
And someone like that.
Somebody in the room just leave the mic so you just leave and recording the
entire time.
It was so I was so bummed out about it.
Um,
cause top dog,
it just in a minute like I'm done,
I'm going to just trying to,
you know,
clean up these files or whatever and then I just turn up that night.
I had to throw my underwear away because he got it.
He could wear it and some of them got into my trousers here again,
so I had to get on the plane and fly with a little,
oh my goal.
His pants.
Yeah.
So that was a funny story.
No,
nothing I could do that'll go home.
Can you have a car car?
But he had to sit on the plane with Gaga on the pants.
So I thought,
yeah,
this wasn't a big deal for the person that sat in there after me.
Imagine you said after that you're sitting in his shit.
Oh,
uh,
okay.
Can you have some glass in your show?
There is class.
There's um,
there's a lot of songs about that.
You know that a lot people make songs about it.
Holy Shit.
That was on your show.
Uh,
oh.
So funny to hear her get mad.
It's my new favorite.
It is fun,
right?
You guys are discussing,
she gets so mad at us talking about it.
We talked about farting,
shinning peeing so much.
You know what your dad really liked,
right,
is when we talked about how we yellow on each other's yellow.
Yeah.
He goes,
I like to let my,
my piece sit there too.
And then my mosaic,
he'll pee like five times and not flushed and we brought,
we were real proud about that.
Yeah.
I think Tom and I do want to hear his line reads.
Yeah,
I got him to do some too.
These lines
here.
Your mom had a bout of diarrhea.
Is that,
maybe that may be why she had a 22nd part.
Yeah.
Shit.
Diarrhea.
That's true.
It was such a big fart though.
Yeah.
So upset.
Something funny.
Okay.
Top dog line reads.
Read the title.
Yeah.
Total dad jokes.
Dad Boehner.
Yeah,
so the top of the page that I hand him,
it says top dog line reads.
Right.
Something funny.
Okay.
Top dog line reads.
I could not put dummy.
You know,
I love my cheese.
This is top dog and I just farted.
It smells bad,
but at least I know what's coming.
There's no feeling like killing the enemy.
Well,
there's keeping the lady life for a week in my basement barrier in a field,
but still the enemy is the enemy
is good.
I remember when I farted in Burp at the same time,
like remember my first kiss,
actually,
it all happened on the same day.
He's laughing through his lines.
That's why a lot of people burp and Fart or Fart,
then birth.
But when you do them at the same time,
that's magic that it's a double pipe.
Classic.
Nice.
It's good.
Go to [inaudible] dot com and click on the store.
Buy stuff from my buddy Tommy.
Would you marry your dad?
I'm just glass.
Glass,
glass,
glass all day.
Go to a thousand ranch dotcom and buy some tickets to see those big mushy
purples.
I have a big announcement.
I'm Polly.
I'm bi.
I'm married a squirrel.
Would you like to come to the wedding coach of the Orlando Airport Terminal B
gate 55 men's through third install on the left.
That's where I left my trousers.
Okay.
See now the reason that charros laughing is she thinks that it's a a made up
that right.
And that's why afterwards she goes,
I thought it was a funny story.
I didn't realize it's true.
Yeah.
So yeah,
that's why you're seeing the,
um,
the laughter is because,
oh,
this is made up.
But once she's horrified later or when I played earlier is because she realizes
it's true.
Okay.
You got that.
I need you to do the Tommy,
would you marry your dad line again and,
and that one you just did again.
Okay.
Tommy,
would you marry your dad?
He sounds so serious.
That's my favorite part.
Funny Tommy.
Cause he's bad at acting,
which is where it's so funny.
Yeah.
But he's too eager.
Like your mom,
her reluctance is what makes her hilarious.
Your Dad wants to be in Showbiz.
Yeah.
And that's why it's,
it's like different,
it's different.
I wouldn't say it's,
it's just different.
No,
that's,
you nailed the analysis of why one works better.
Yeah.
Comedically.
Yes.
But his reads are so flat.
It's funny,
but that one actually,
that's the one,
the reason that's the funniest is because I think he delivers that line the
best.
Right.
Because to him,
he,
he actually married your dad.
He doesn't know why.
That's funny.
And that's why it's funny because he's reading it sincerely.
Right.
Or something.
What'd you marry your dad?
He's saying it like it's a real thing to ask me.
Yeah,
that's good.
They did great.
Just do it again.
Okay.
Tommy,
would you marry your dad?
Go to the lender and Bart and I repair for it.
Go to Lando,
Eric.
Okay.
Go to the Orlando Airport.
Terminal B gate 55 men's room.
Third Stall on the left.
That's where I left my trousers.
I am the fart master.
I fart.
I shit.
And I teach.
I love stamps.
All this good buddy.
Okay,
good.
Yeah,
he,
um,
he wants to be,
uh,
an actor or yeah.
Yeah,
but I like it.
He,
he's the best when he's not trying hard,
which is the best one.
He sincere,
but that's so hard for him to do.
Right.
That's why the phone calls,
I used to call my dad and go,
I'm going to call you in 10 minutes for the shower for my show.
Right.
And if you listen to the old phone calls,
not early,
early,
but once he realized people were listening.
Yeah.
I told him like,
oh,
all these people are saying I liked to call with you.
Then there was a period where he was like,
oh,
and he would like be all prepped and that's when I started to call him from a
like a different line.
Yeah.
So that he would just answer.
I go,
Oh,
Hey dad.
He,
oh,
what's up buddy?
Yeah.
So when you hear him answer like that,
basically the last few years,
it's because he just thinks I'm calling to say hi.
Yeah.
It's definitely more natural.
You got to catch them off guard.
Got To catch them off guard.
Yes.
Chairs are so fucking uncomfortable.
I'm just trying to get comfortable.
I know,
man.
I know.
That's right.
He did a really good job.
They both did a really
great job,
people,
but you should have no fucking problem.
Wow.
That's funny.
What does she want?
I don't know where she is.
Make it easy for you.
Fucking get on
your menu up there,
then take it off the menu.
It's not available.
Wow.
That's um hm.
I think we have to subway people.
Oh yeah.
Because let's see.
This one says,
sounds like Maria went to subway.
She's losing her shit and then I swear there's another one.
There's another one.
She's got hungry,
but she does,
that's all hungry.
Uh Wow.
There's a,
there's multiple.
Let me see if there's another subway.
I feel like there's another subway.
But you're freaking out at the subway.
Employees like,
dude,
you're not the four seasons relaxed.
I know,
right?
God,
people get so mad about that shit.
Poor person just is working at subway.
Yeah.
Just trying not to throw up every day,
smelling that shit.
No.
It also,
so I don't like subway anymore.
I don't give a fuck about none of that.
I'm spending money.
You going give me what I asked for.
That's why I'm special to you.
I'm special to you
baby
can cheeks.
Yes ma'am.
No,
you are ignorant.
Bitch.
Yo Momma.
That bitch you faggot ass.
I don't come outside.
We can get it cause I'm a real Nigga.
Whoa.
Jeez.
You know when someone's voice trembles too.
It's so much rage.
She's mad.
Oh yeah,
that's true.
Gentleman.
Just something else is going on.
Okay.
Hey this Nigga,
that's what you are.
Come on.
I'm like Yo Mama for having Yo ass.
You should have swallowed Yo punk ass.
She sorta swallow show punk case.
It's Carlin.
Whoa.
Let us,
you could take some day later saw taking a little salt and pepper.
Yes ma'am.
I wanted them all in the oven.
Hilarious
man.
Is it subway like the nastiest now when you look at it,
I used to eat that shit on the road and it's so fake.
Like the meat is totally,
it's not good.
I mean sucks.
Even the lettuce is frozen.
Sometimes they'll have like ice on it.
When you're doing fast food options,
what's the better?
We've all driven through nowhere and been like,
all right dude.
At least I can get spinach and avocado on some shit,
you know
and all my other sandwiches because I was having for
no,
just stop talking to me while I'm talking to her professional bitch ass Nigga
and I'm gonna show you that tomorrow.
Okay.
Wow.
But when y'all clothes I said Yo punk ass when you get off o Si yo bitch ass
when you get off,
I'm going to see the same attitude.
Is that a kid with her?
No.
You bring up.
Same thing you just put on everything else.
That's too much lettuce.
She's able to go back and forth though.
That's kind of the impressive one.
Yeah,
right.
She didn't lose her
cool that much.
Nothing ass Nigga bitch
call my mother fucker.
Why you talking?
Shit so he could come at you.
Right?
It's so intense and then she's going to be like Mayo.
Take some of that later
because I want to say all I asked you was all Italian.
I ain't say nothing else to make your job smoother.
I said all sandwiches was
not for that.
Well,
let's go back to Maria.
Maria at subway is a little more default from Chanel with extra names like you
should have had it available then why is it unavailable?
I like white people.
Rage over silly things.
More over silly things.
Over black people rage.
Well,
yeah.
Why?
People getting mad about,
why is it that there
everyone looking at it?
It's not available.
You think she's asking Matt?
I don't know,
but why was the other lady yelling?
I'm like,
I don't know what started that fight.
I don't know if she was mad at him at a menu.
That's what I'm saying.
Because somebody started after it started after the altercation began,
you know?
Yeah.
See,
I don't know what the other ladies,
man,
I know that this lady is
mad at something stupid menu.
It is what she does have that
of,
there's one of be on the menu is a total white chick thing.
Oh yeah.
This is the white people get mad about shit that does not matter.
Yeah,
and titled to everything.
You know that,
but if you know that,
then don't expect it to be different.
That's on you do.
One thing that I noticed in both,
uh,
subway scenarios.
Yeah.
Everybody minds their fucking business.
No one gets involved.
Well,
who's going to school this woman.
I know,
but it's just funny.
This guy is like,
I'm not even looking at this woman.
I'm tuning this out.
Crazy person.
Okay,
and what's she,
what's really bothering her?
It's not that there's something not on the subway menu.
You know her husband and her fought this morning or she didn't get what she
wanted somewhere else.
It ain't about the subway folks.
It never is.
It's never about the sandwich.
Never about whether they have parmesan cheese now.
None of that shit bothers you.
Jesus.
The pork.
Yay.
Tell who the head office.
Oh,
tell your head office to make it.
I thought she was saying something really different.
I like this guy.
He's like,
she's losing her mind.
Fucking bullshit.
God
over what?
Over.
There's,
there's no bread left for the sandwich.
You want go crazy.
Go to another subway.
We considered that she's lived upstairs for six years.
That's what she said.
Go.
Don't go to another one.
Call ahead.
Yeah,
don't eat at subway.
How about that.
Just eat somewhere else.
This guy reminds me of you by the way here.
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh Shit goes,
go,
go in there and cover it up.
Cat Litter.
He's dry.
He's not speaking.
He's driving.
I don't want it.
You can't handle it.
Why are you doing?
It's done.
That guy's a Bert body too.
Did you see it
here?
That big old Burt body.
Why are you upset?
Because you know I don't like the Barf in the dry heat.
Yeah,
it was,
um,
he just couldn't have some people just can't handle it.
I felt like that during some diaper changes.
No,
for fat.
Good one.
Yeah.
Good job.
Kid is fat.
That's true.
I'm going to see Bart one tomorrow.
Where at the show were,
we were both doing the laugh factory.
He's going to be super bummed because you're so much skinnier than he is.
I know.
By the way,
we didn't hear back from Fred the glassine,
but uh,
we got this video of him slapping a bear.
Cool.
That's going through a trashcan and he gets so excited and it's also toilets in
his yard.
You want to see?
It's really amazing.
What is wrong with humanity?
I don't know who's calling on a,
God damn it.
I love it.
This is a brand new pooter.
Oh my God.
There you are.
Errors on the dumpster.
Let's try and sneak home.
So this is like his idea of a lot of fun.
Right?
I wouldn't fuck with a bear.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Fred.
That's Fred.
Those toilets.
Oh with awesome.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
And there's toilets in his back yard.
Yeah.
And by the way,
he's in Colorado.
That's where he's from and sure not originally.
Um,
the toilets are
okay.
Y'all come on.
Bear is a Colorado my backyard.
It's
two toilets in his backyard,
by the way,
is Fred?
My Dad cause would be that excited about that.
The high five really solidifies his position as a dad boner.
Yeah,
high fiving is just the lamest.
Yeah.
He really loves high fives to
court.
All Dad.
Boners that's what they do.
Real Dad.
Yeah.
It's a real dad noise.
Yeah,
it's pretty good.
Pretty good.
Real dads only.
Ah,
man.
Yeah.
Real moms don't approve of bad behavior like that.
No real moms.
They shake their heads,
they go,
by the way.
Um
Mm
Burton,
I Barton I we weigh in in two weeks.
Well,
you're already ahead of the curb.
I know you're so ahead of the curb.
He's got no chance.
None.
I got a text from this,
a buddy of mine in Florida who was at the radio station that Burt did on
Thursday and he goes,
uh,
I think you're going to win.
And I go,
why?
He goes,
I just gave him,
I just watched him drink six,
um,
drinks this morning at radio.
He had three breakfast sandwiches and two,
uh,
two breeds.
No,
he's done.
Yeah.
Hey Jean,
how,
until you do,
can I get a grilled steak stuffed taco supreme stadio hold a stake case.
Surrito
and,
Hey,
what did you want to draw up?
Yeah,
can I get in for cheese?
Rollups
and that'll do it.
Yup.
All right.
Thanks Mommy.
That's Dave.
That's really good.
I like the,
Hey Hitler.
He threw it on there.
It was really unexpected.
Hey Hitler,
what?
What'd you want?
Good work.
Very,
very unexpected.
Thank you.
Hey Jean.
Still your money.
The money.
It's me.
Jeans.
Uh Hey James.
Hi Mommy.
It's your genes.
Hey Mommy.
Yeah,
I know you're the water champ.
Thank you for the water for as long as I've known you.
Thank you.
Infuriating.
Yeah.
Actually you have to admit something though.
No,
this past week.
dude,
you've seen me taking that big plastic one up.
What are you taught?
Workouts?
What are you talking about?
You're blatantly lying.
What plastic ones?
The big water tumbler.
I've been,
I've been drinking that.
Oh,
you know what?
I saw the water tumbler cause I saw that it was upstairs in the bedroom and it
was full.
And then I saw it fall and then I brought it down because it was full.
I probably had five gallons of water.
Oh my God.
You lie.
No,
I don't.
So my drinking,
I don't want to hear it.
I don't want water.
Oh my fucking God.
That's true.
I was actually stopped and I was like,
man,
I was just impressed with myself.
I had to stop and go like,
you're the fucking and enough,
I don't want to hear you.
That's true.
Your lies true.
Very.
I haven't really want Korean food.
I am dying.
Um,
well it's not going to happen.
So it's going to happen.
I'm going to go alone.
Yeah.
After patrion.
Yes.
Put that shit down.
Patrion put it shut down after we're doing.
Um,
oh cool.
Somebody sent you a glass and glass.
Somebody said,
let's see.
Burdis fat.
Hey,
mommy's just wanting to submit some more proof of who the number one water
champion is as if we need more proof.
Tuesday showed the ice house was great.
Obviously a result of superior hydration.
Keep up the good work.
Thanks genes.
This email came in and look what they circled.
One photo shopped after the show.
Photo shopped somebody of the show.
It's daylight out.
How's that after?
Because they have lights on outside.
How's are really good?
Yeah.
That's not so anyways,
so first of all,
jobs all,
thank you for submitting your art.
Yeah.
Thank you very much.
Like how thin your beard was.
Did you have an email you wanted to read now?
A new fart.
Smell him.
Mommy's I moved in with my fiance over little year ago,
little over a year ago.
And now my farts and brown smell like his,
we are currently working opposite shifts and aren't even eating the same foods.
I'm very scared that I have lost my fart and Brown identity.
What do I do?
Lots of love,
Hannah.
I think you should take that one.
Jeans,
first of all.
Um,
really interesting problem.
Yeah,
real issue.
They're life changing issue.
I mean,
look,
on occasion I've,
my farts have smelled like toms,
but that's because we've eaten similarly.
Now here's the real question.
Do Your Brown smell alike?
And I doubt that mountain men's Brown tends to smell more pungent than women's
Brown.
So I wouldn't stress too much about you so far.
And Brown and Brown.
Oh Wow.
And you're not eating the same thing.
I find that hard to believe you're sharing a home.
Uh,
it could be bacteria in the house that you guys are sharing.
Yeah,
it could be a beverage.
Are you guys sharing the same coffee?
Because coffee makes you brown and fired.
The main thing I would just emphasize is that this is a breaking point in the
relationship.
I mean,
you need to solve this problem.
Um,
maybe take a trip,
I would say into the wilderness together and pitch a tent face to face.
Don't even bring fire with,
see if you can make it and,
and see what happens to your browns when you're out there.
When you're away from your house is what you're saying is on the line to see how
the stress is affecting my digestive system.
It's a really interesting point.
That's what I would do.
Okay.
Um Hm.
It is upsetting for her though.
It did not have your own brown identity.
I don't think that that's fair.
It's really interesting.
True water champ.
Mind Games,
someone
writes,
they said I had a breakthrough on the identity of true water champion when I
started engaging my own water competition with my girlfriend.
My girlfriend was formerly very adverse to drinking water instead of nagging her
and trying to bull here into drinking it.
I drew inspiration from your mom's house and simply stated that I was the water
champion and I pointed to her full glass of water as evidence of this human
beings being prideful creatures.
She immediately disagreed,
pounded the water to her face and has since started drinking way more water to
prove that she is the real water champion.
She doesn't realize this was my main plan all along and no matter how much water
she drinks,
I will always and forever be the water champ regionally of course,
because it was I who put us both back on the path to hydration health.
A Win for her is it went for me as long as she drinks or water.
If you listen in earlier episodes,
Mommy,
Tina actually pulled this exact maneuver on Tommy when she was worried about the
color of his urine.
So even though Tommy Buns,
giant bear that he is drinks more water by volume,
not true.
Now that the country has been true,
all of his water gains are points scored for Tina because she essentially
tricked him.
Yeah,
thank you.
Drinking more water.
If you think if you go back and listen to the origin or the water championship,
there really is no doubt that Mommy Tina is playing head games with Tommy.
Absolutely right.
Thank you for your observation.
Well,
I guess we picked up another retarded listener,
so there's all,
there's that stupid.
Um,
uh Oh this one says I'll keep it.
I'll keep it short because you've got to read the other emails,
but that hairstyle is called the skull.
It the one that I want Tina to have.
Yeah,
let's try,
let's see.
I don't like this hairstyle.
This,
this is what I do.
Why?
This is what I want you to have though.
Why do you insist on this?
No,
I don't like that at all.
That is it.
That's it.
She's right.
He's right.
I would say this one is the best,
most like it.
So we just,
we cut the top off.
You tell me that you have a special coming out and the promo is you with no hair
on top but long hair on the sides and that that's not going to draw attention to
them listening.
You have to think in terms of,
I need to drive people's interest into clicking play.
Right.
So wouldn't that help do it?
Oh,
a woman with his haircut?
Yes.
And can you click on the third from the right there?
Yeah,
I know this guy.
he's fine.
Um,
yes.
But only when you start to make your retarded comedy albums.
Why are you making it?
We're talking about you.
You do the world's only retarded comedian and I,
I'll do the skull it.
Oh,
Phil Spector's gotta go one bell.
That was weird.
I mean,
that's a weird Gallagher Gallagher.
Yeah.
Hogan.
Hannah had that going
for a while.
Yeah.
Anyways,
I still think it's a really good idea that I had for you.
Thank you.
Here you go.
This is you right here.
He's got the blonde hair.
See,
it's not gonna.
It's not a successful look.
Well,
I have to respectfully disagree.
Let me see if there's any topics we're forgetting.
Okay.
I'm about to
play the closing song
and then we got it.
We got it.
We're going to get some food.
We're going to go pantry on.
Put the picture on patrion.com/mom that's where we do the page on episode.
Yeah,
we got some packages to open,
blah,
blah.
You guys got to take it off.
If it,
I'll have it and it's on the,
you said take it out of the fucking menu is yet says you have it on the
menu.
You imagined that anytime a restaurant ran out of anything,
they go,
we have to remove it from the menu.
Now it's not.
And then we'll reprint these tomorrow.
She has is that it's a chain restaurant.
Yeah,
and it's a corporate thing.
Like if you're going to in regular restaurant,
they run out of something and in order enough,
whatever.
It's Saturday night.
But dude,
snow
dude,
Bro.
Bro It up with the dude.
Super Gay,
Bro.
All right.
This was a lot of fun.
Thank you guys for listening.
Uh,
put that shit down.
Your mom's house,
podcast.com please click on it.
See what we got come to our live shows was on February 12th,
the sperm vine improve.
Come see us.
Do the show live your mom's house podcast live February 12th,
2017 you go
buy jeans,
this,
this.
Okay,
just
keep going.
And what's glass on glass?
And I'm like,
well,
someone or let them take all my pussy with that on my pussy.